[Applause]
hi everybody my name is anneka gupta and
i'm really honored to be here tonight to
share my story amongst seven other
incredibly inspiring women
I started at live ramp as a software
engineer back in 2010 after I graduated
from college little did I know that
eight years later I would be at the same
company leading an organization of
almost 400 people as co-ceo back in 2010
we were just a 25-person startup trying
to find product market fit and as a
software engineer I spent my days
hacking away on different projects
pulling all-nighters when our sales team
decided to sell something that we didn't
actually have and through this product
process of experimentation and iteration
we finally found a product that was
going to take us on our first wave of
growth libraries and marketing
technology companies I'm not going to
get into the details of what it is we do
or what our initial product was but when
we hit that stage I decided that I
wanted to move into product management
without a very clear idea about what
product management really was so I did
everything from handling customer
support to troubleshooting engineering
issues to developing the roadmap of what
we were going to build it was super
exciting and this was an early time in
the company when we were starting to get
a lot of customers starting to get a lot
of feedback and really starting to grow
and I would have continued down that
path had it not been for about a year
later the woman that was running our
marketing team left the company and I
really wanted to learn about marketing
because as a product manager I had come
from a technical background so I had the
technical side of being a product
manager down but I didn't feel like I
had the external market facing side of
product management down so I went to the
leadership of our company and I offered
to help on a few of the marketing
projects that were in flight and I had
worked with the marketing team before on
setting up our website
and setting up some of our marketing
tools to run campaigns and our
leadership team came back to me and said
hey you know you can either run a few of
these projects or you can run the
marketing team while we look to hire
someone so I thought okay this is great
it could be a great experience for me
I'm gonna learn a lot so I jumped
wholeheartedly into running marketing
without really knowing again what
marketing did or was and we were trying
to make a hire and first we thought that
we were gonna make a hire for the team
in about three months it ended up taking
us a year to hire someone for the role
so I ran marketing for a year and about
three months into the role our CEO came
up to me and he said hey you know we
really need someone to run recruiting
and recruiting is a lot like marketing
instead of marketing to specific to
potential customers you're marketing to
potential candidates and people that are
gonna join the company so again I
thought that this might be a great
learning experience for me so I dove
into running the recruiting team I ran
marketing and recruiting in this early
stage of growth for about a year and at
the end of the year we hired a VP of
Marketing who could really scale our
marketing programs and take them beyond
the guerilla marketing programs that I
had created and the leadership team came
back to me and said hey what do you want
to do next you can stay on the marketing
team and continue to be working in
marketing and growing your skillset
there you can run our customer support
team
you can run our HR and recruiting team
or you can run our product team and
product was really where my heart was at
I really enjoyed my year as a product
manager and that was really even when I
was in college that was a role that
sounded just super exciting to me
because you got to be at the
intersection of technology and strategy
and your market message so I decided to
take on this role running the product
team and I ran product for three and a
half years I ran product through our
acquisition in subsequent hyper growth
stage where our revenues grew from 30
million to 200 million and our team grew
from 30 from 70 people to close to 400
people and during that time
it was lots of fun I learned a lot and
the product was wildly successful but I
started to think to myself what do I
want to do next where does this where's
this going to take me and I knew I could
continue down a career in product
management and there's a lot of rules
now and a lot of opportunities to lead
product teams but deep down inside I was
not a specialist one of the things that
I'd really enjoyed about everything all
the twists and turns that my career had
taken me was the fact that I got to do
so many different things and I got to
explore and I got to be a generalist and
even in college I didn't want to be
siloed to a single major so I chose an
interdisciplinary major where I could
work on many different take classes in
many many different subjects so I
started talking to mentors and they
asked me have you considered maybe
thinking about being a CEO and at first
I was a little hesitant and then I
started saying yeah okay that's that's
what I want to do so I started telling
people I want to be a CEO but deep down
inside I had huge misgivings about my
ability to do this I looked around me at
the CEOs I knew the founder CEO of our
company his predecessor CEOs that are
wildly revered like Jeff Bezos that are
Bart Zuckerberg or Steve Jobs and I
looked at them and I felt like they were
not like me I felt like I had a
different personality and I looked at
them and they seemed so bold and
self-confident and fearless and willing
to bet their whole company on a vision
of the future that was potentially
controversial so I was you know all this
was going on in my head and then in
August of 2017 about six months ago I
got a call from our CEO and he told me
that he was going to take a position as
a CEO of a startup company a company
that he'd been on the board of the
company that had just raised a lot of
money from Softbank and he felt like
that was the right time to move on in my
first feeling at that moment was fear
because I knew what was coming next we
had talked about succession planning and
our CEO told me that he wanted me
and our chief operating officer to
become co-ceos of live ramp and I
remember the day that we announced this
to our executive team I was so anxious
and so scared I was and still am the
youngest person on our executive team
and I knew that other members of the
executive team would think would ask
themselves why were they not chosen as a
successor why was I chosen over them I
also looked at all of them and I knew
that they could all do their job much
better than I could do their job so what
did I really have to offer in the first
month and month and a half after the
transition I was paralyzed by fear I
felt so insecure about what I could do
and making any changes that I basically
didn't do anything I mean I did my job
but I kept things running but I was
afraid to make any major changes and
then we started to hit a point where
morale was beginning to slip within the
company and this was due to a lot of
things mainly growing pains we had a
bunch of longtime live rampers leave the
company we had a bunch of product
stability issues we got feedback from
people that there was it was hard to
make decisions and it was hard to figure
out who to go to to get things done we
had got more feedback that people felt
like the leadership team wasn't being
transparent about the challenges in the
organization and on top of that I got
feedback some pretty harsh feedback from
some of our executives that now reported
to me one executive told me that I was
micromanaging him in that if I continued
this no experienced leader would want to
work for me another executive told me
that I was perpetuating politics within
the organization so all of a sudden all
of my fears and insecurities are pretty
coming very very real and I realized
that I had to do something so I started
acting and I made a bunch of changes I
started ruthlessly prioritizing my time
I started changing the way that our
internal communications were being
managed and how we were leading our
executive meetings every week and
helping us focus on really the big
issues at hand versus just the small
things that come up every day
and the biggest change I made well
I started reaching out and asking people
for help and this was a big change for
me I restarted reaching out to people to
help me even if I felt like it was
outside of the scope of their job even
if I felt like I was imposing on them
for by asking for help and even if I
felt like I was being incredibly selfish
by asking them to do something that I
could do myself the last thing I did was
I started being very open about my fears
and vulnerabilities and this culminated
in an all-hands meeting that I led for
the company where I was supposed to
share my takeaways and learnings from
the first 90 days and I decided to stand
up in front of the company and talk
about the fact that I was really working
on trying to ask for help so I went
through the top eight concerns that I'd
heard from the team and it was all the
things I talked about like are we losing
our culture what are we having a hard
time retaining people all of these
things and for each item I talked about
what we were gonna do as a leadership
team to solve this and I made an ask to
the rest of the company about how they
can help solve that problem and that was
a real turning point because the
organization felt heard and I felt like
I was really making a difference
since then it's not been all rainbows
and unicorns there's been a lot of
moments of pure joy and there's been a
lot of moments of hardship I've had to
make really difficult decisions about
where to take the company decisions that
were incredibly gut-wrenching I've had
to hear through the grapevine that
people disagreed with some of the ways I
did things and attributed that to me
being an inexperienced leader however
the sum total of these experiences had
has made me a better person it has
forced me into a continuous cycle of
self improvement and it has forced me to
face my deepest fears and insecurities
my hope in sharing this story with you
is that you will be inspired to step
into leadership roles that you may not
feel ready for even to this day at least
a couple times a week I hear the voices
in my head that voices up self-doubts
voices that question my self-confidence
voices of fear and in those moments I
tell
myself that while the great leaders are
remembered by the bold decisions they
make there their courage is defined by
acting in the face of fear not in the
absence of it thank you
[Applause]